Oh what is it about cracking necks
that's so Oh disturbing maybe it's
because the neck is a pretty sensitive
area for most people but maybe it's that
sickly sound effect that comes with the
cracking of you know whatever or maybe
I'm just oversensitive anyway for as
impactful of a moment as good old mummy
ganondorf's neck crack was newer fans of
the series will be surprised to hear
that he wasn't the first one to make a
snap crackle pop with his head holder
oh no let me take you back to a villain
from what is undoubtedly one of the best
games in a series of games where each
one is arguably one of the best except
for these guys Twilight Princess
introduced the world to the villainy of
the villainous villain that goes by the
name of Zant like ant at the end of the
game Oh major spoiler alert by the way
even though the game came out over 10
years ago mm-hmm at the end of the game
when Lincoln Zelda defeat Ganondorf
quote-unquote once and for all Ganondorf
calls once again upon the divine prank
the power of the Triforce of power that
rests within him he holds his hand in
the air awaiting the surge of renewed
strength that will enable him to cheat
his impending death as he experienced
once before but to his dismay instead
what he then sees is Zant who died a
little while ago he just stares at him
for a few seconds and then and
immediately ganondorf's life escapes his
body and he dies standing straight up
with the Master Sword stabbed through
his bod for as legendary of a scene as
that was it's also incredibly confusing
what did the Zant head thing mean why
did he even show up here what does he
have to do with Ganondorf the power of
the triforce in the same kind of style
as i've done with one of my previous
videos explaining that haunting linear
cutscene also from this game i'm going
to explain what you just saw and because
what I'm gonna say isn't confirmed to be
canon this is what we call a theory a
Zelda theory let's begin actually real
quick guys before getting into the Nitty
Gritty of this theory make sure you're
not just at the mercy of the YouTube
algorithm but are subscribed
the channel with that Bell icon so you
never miss out on an upload here at MMB
and of course after you're done watching
leave a like if you enjoyed the video
anyhoo zzzz I'm going to begin by just
straight-up telling you what I think the
whole scene represents I think
ganondorf's Triforce hand shine is more
like a request for power and xan's neck
snap is the denial of seven West now in
order to explain that hypothesis first
we're going to talk about the
significance of this entire moment here
with the Zant's neck doing the crack
thing and g-man straight up getting
deleted I wanted to point out that this
scene is so impactful because it's
happened to Ganondorf before you see
after the events of the child ending of
Ocarina of Time Ganondorf is tried for
his crimes and straight-up sentenced to
death death by stabbing that is through
the belly seem familiar and that's not
the only similarity not only was he
stabbed in the exact same spot that link
stabs him in at the end of the game but
when he's dying
the Triforce emblem on his hand begins
to glow with the power of the goddesses
saving him from his otherwise certain
death the inability for even the sages
to explain why Ganondorf was one of the
chosen to bear the power of the Gods is
referred to as the infamous divine prank
and ultimately took them so off-guard
and resulted in Ganondorf killing the
sage of water but let's rewind and break
this scene down to better understand
what happened with Santa at the end of
the game so first up we have ganondorf's
death or near death he's mortally
wounded bleeding out moments away from
meeting his makers at the last moment
his hand begins to glow was it glowing
before when he was chained up or when he
initially got stabbed nope it was not
and once it does begin to glow Ganondorf
the strength not only returns but
multiplies in force but what happened to
make his Triforce the divine prank come
to fruition why didn't it oh I don't
know prevent him from getting stabbed in
the first place well simply put I think
this gives us some hint as to how
exactly ganondorf's piece of the
Triforce works think of it as a switch
that isn't turned on all the time but
rather a switch that ganador has to call
upon when needed and can access upon his
intent or upon his request maybe he
actually didn't activate this power
prior to being stabbed because he didn't
even know he could do this at this point
almost kicking the bucket his thoughts
became
something like I want to live and this
request went through and he was granted
the power to not only dodge his own
death but also literally break the
physical chains holding him back from
defeating his shiny enemies so who
approved this request exactly did the
goddesses themselves see the demon king
dying and go oh wait a second I want
that guy to live have you seen this
rehydrated fan right I don't think so I
think the goddess has had nothing to do
with it actually and that since
ganondorf's power lies within himself at
the moment he approved his own request
at the moment now the very astute of you
watching this and paying attention to
everywhere that I'm saying already
probably know where I'm going with this
theory but stay tuned I'm about to start
drawing connections right after g-man
deletes water guy he gets catapulted
into Twilight place sometime between
this event and the events surrounding
the game's ending
g-man meets with the same man who
immediately Revere's the floating
Ganondorf head as a god now here's where
it gets interesting Ganondorf saw
potential for his master plan in mister
Zant which led him to make a mistake
that would unbeknownst to him lead to
his eventual actual death at the hands
of a certain farmer boy Ganondorf tells
Zant that he will house his power Inns
and granting him the ability to do
things like curse midnight into being an
adorable flying imp break the mirror of
Twilight and pass in between the world
of light in the world of Twilight at
will oh and also survive being in the
light world when the Twilight not which
by the way is a pretty good segue into a
neat theory on Midna and the Triforce of
wisdom I did a while back link will be
in the description below and on the top
right if you want to check that out
anyway on Ganondorf side of things
he gave Zant part of his power in order
to have a powerful pawn capable of
paving the way to his eventual retaking
of Hyrule Castle the same goal he had
originally in ocarina of time he didn't
care about Zant necessarily and never
shows any sort of remorse over the
little guy's death at the hands of a
pretty ticked in platy but okay why am I
going over all this
well now that these pieces have been set
let's look once more at the events of
ganondorf's death in the climactic
ending of this epic four-part final
battle linking Ganondorf literally spar
against each other in a legendary
one-on-one sword fight to the death
while Zelda watches from beyond the
magic
enhanced barriers after X farmer guy
finally knocks g-man to the ground and
stabs him through the gut with the
Master Sword the fight has officially
ended Ganondorf stands vows this is not
the end then makes the same request for
power he learned from long ago at which
point Zant randomly shows up cracks his
neck to the side and ganondorf's life
fades away when I first saw this scene
the only thing that made sense for
Ganondorf dying here as opposed to
earlier in the game was that it was the
Master Sword that prevented Ganondorf
survival but if the sword seals away
evil why would it prevent the flow of
the power of the Triforce regardless of
the Bearer I mean are we trying to say
that the Master Sword is more powerful
than the Triforce itself no I think the
answer has to do with the fact that
Ganondorf is not the only bearer of the
Triforce of power at this point in time
you heard me
remember when Ganondorf gave part of his
power to Zant consider this
what if Ganondorf no longer had enough
power within himself to revive himself
alone I mean he had expended quite a bit
of power in encasing the castle in a
magic barrier possessing Zelda
transforming into dark beast again and
creating ghostly enemies and even
affecting the weather and directing more
many impenetrable barriers and so much
more it's entirely possible that he
spent all of the power he had left
housed within himself while fighting
link and this time when he requested
more power the request went to where the
remainder of his power lied in Zant Zant
has been dead this whole time watching
over his quote unquote God as he
witnessed the complete lack of concern
over his own death and his own people
and his gods defeat at the hands of some
boy I think it's safe to say that Zant's
faith in this false god was not only
tested but was lost entirely and when
this god that was supposed to be
all-powerful and was supposed to give
him eternal reign over the Twilight
instead reached out to him to save his
dying life the pathetic request was
denied
and that is my theory on what zan's
cracking neck meant at the end of
Twilight Princess it's partially
symbolic and partially literal but what
do you think
am I on the right track or completely
crazy let me know in a comment below and
hey thank you guys so very much for
watching as always humongous thanks goes
to all of my many supporters including
some big new faces
say hello to Selina Oh Megan uh Vios
Jake Zak dins Flame and Patrick and a
massive hello to a brand new mega
supporter candy skulls you guys I am so
humbled and so amazed that so many of
you want to support the channel I can't
thank you enough
enjoy your benefits and welcome to my
elite crew if you watching would like to
see your name up here at the end of my
videos and some exclusive perks click
the join button below or visit the links
in the description also down there are
links to my social media pages so come
follow me on Twitter that's all I've got
for this one so as always this is masts
antenna bandits signing out I hope
everyone stays safe and has a wonderful
rest of your day
[Music]